Besides introducing the terminology
of alphabets, strings, and
languages, the major goal of this lesson
is to convince you that some
functions are not computable.
Central to our argument will
be the difference between
countably infinite sets and
uncountably infinite sets.
If you weren't familiar with this
distinction already, you may be thinking
to yourself, infinity's
a strange enough idea by itself.
Now I have to deal with two of them?
Well, it isn't as bad as all that.
A countably infinite set is
one that you can enumerate.
That is, you can say,
this is the first element, this is
the second element, and so forth.
And, this is the really important part,
eventually give a number to
every element in the set.
For some sets,
an enumeration is straight forward.
Take the even numbers.
We can say that two's the first one,
four is the second,
six the third and so forth.
For some sets like the rationals,
you've to be a little bit
clever to find an enumeration.
We'll see the trick for
enumerating them in a little bit.
And for some sets,
like the real numbers,
it doesn't matter how clever you are,
there simply is no enumeration.
These are the uncountable sets.
In what follows, we'll argue that
the set of all strings over an alphabet
is countable and give a few other
results that will be useful for
thinking about countability in general.
Then we will show that the set
of languages is uncountable.
Let's make this notion of countable and
uncountable sets precise
with a formal definition.
We say that a a set is
countable if it is finite or
if there is a one-to-one correspondence
with the natural numbers.
A one-to-one correspondence,
by the way, is a function that
is one to one, meaning that
no two elements of the domain get mapped
to the same element of the range.
And also onto,
meaning that every element of the range
is mapped to by
an element of the domain.
For example, here is a one-to-one
correspondence between the integers,
1 through 6, and the set of
permutations of three elements.
Now, in general, the existence
of a one-to-one correspondence
implies that the two
sets have the same size.
That is, the same number of elements.
And this actually holds even for
infinite sets.
That is why we say that there
are as many even natural numbers
as there are natural numbers.
Because it's easy to establish
a one-to-one correspondence between
the two sets.
F of N is equal to 2 N, for example.
For our purposes, we are most
interested in showing that for
any finite alphabet, the set of strings
over that alphabet is countable.